لقد تحدثت مع أنطوان لأنه
كان يشعر بخيبة أمل وبصراحة كل شيء
بصراحة هذا أمر مفهوم
طبيعي، إنه رد فعل يمكن سماعه
قلت له أنه في مكانه سيكون لي
ربما نفس رد الفعل وهو يبلغ من العمر 32 عامًا
أمضى 10 سنوات في المنتخب الفرنسي
كان لاعبا أكثر من مهم
ربما واحد أو أكثر من لاعب
مهم لجو أفكار الناس لذلك
من الطبيعي أنه من الطبيعي أن يكون لديه
هذه خيبة الأمل ولدي ما أقول
هذا عندما أكون الكابتن
وابن القبطان أنا لست له
متفوقة من سوف
مرافقتي مع أنطوان في
القيادة يجب أن نغلق هذا الباب أمامها
لا أحد لأنه في بعض الأحيان هناك
هناك قادة طبيعيون في بعض الأحيان
هناك شخص ما في يوم من الأيام هو في بلده
مرحبا يريد التحدث يقول شيئا
شيء متماسك وبناء
بالنسبة للمجموعة يجب علينا إغلاق الباب
الجميع أحرار في التعبير عن أنفسهم
في هذه المجموعة هذا هو الفريق
فرنسا ليست ملكا لأحد